el ministro de asuntos exteriores de
israel twittean árabe mientras el
embajador de los emiratos árabes unidos-
publicada en hebreo saludando a lo que
llaman un acuerdo comercial histórico
que traerá un crecimiento cooperación y
sueños más grandes desde que
normalizaron las relaciones en 2020 el
comercio se impulsó ahora se eliminarán
los aranceles sobre el 96% de los bienes
lo que se supone que traerá crecimiento
a ambos países y bajará los precios
'israel exportaría productos
tecnológicos diamantes frutas y verduras
mientras emiratos árabes unidos-
exportaría material de construcción
aluminio acero y joyería
estoy segura que esto no solo abre las
oportunidades para la comunidad
empresarial para nuevas iniciativas y
tecnologías en evolución tanto en israel
como los emiratos también inspira a
otros países para que vean que esto es
posible
el objetivo es un comercio bilateral
anual de 10 mil millones de dólares
mucho más que con egipto el aliado árabe
de israel desde hace mucho tiempo aunque
el verdadero objetivo no es el comercio
bilateral sino utilizar el territorio
emiratí como centro para miles de
empresas israelíes que esperan llegar a
los comercios de la región y de toda
asia
la firma se produce en el momento de
mayor tensión entre israel y la
autoridad palestina el domingo
activistas israelíes marcharon por
jerusalén y los emiratos árabes unidos
condenaron lo que denominaron el asalto
al recinto de mezquita de al-aqsa lugar
sagrado para el islam pero también el
más sagrado para el judaísmo los
palestinos habían criticado la
normalización de los lazos con israel el
gobierno emiratí dice que espera que el
diálogo y el comercio traigan paz